جمعهما قتالهما الى جانب الجيش الروسي في
اوكرانيا وفرقهم الاستمرار بالولاء له قوه
احمد الشيشانيه تجد نفسها اليوم في مواجهه
قوات مجموعه فيكنر الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان
قادر على ارسال قوات احمد الى جنوب روسيا
لمساعده الجيش الروسي بالتصدي لتمرد لكن
ماذا نعرف عن تلك القوات قوات احمد شكلها
الرئيس الشيشاني في يونيو عام 2022 واطلق
عليها اسم احمد تيمنا بوالده الزعيم
الشيشاني احمد قديروف في رمزيه محفزه
للمقاتلين تتكون من اربع كتائب وهي احمد
شمال واحمد جنوب واحمد شرق واحمد غرب وحسب
التقارير فان عدد المتطوعين فيها وصل الى
عشره الاف جنطي وهي تمثل جزءا من الجيش
الشيشاني لكنها الشبه تابعه للجيش الروسي
نفذت قواته احمد عدته هجمات في مدن
اوكرانيه وتسلحت باحدث واقوى الاسلحه
الروسيه كما انها تمتلك دبابات ومركبات
تحمل شعار حرف زي وهو شعار دعم القوات
الروسيه في اوكرانيا